how's everybody doing today I got some
awesome news for you that I think you'll
be excited about as you may have noticed
lately I've been doing a lot of
collaborations with people after the
schmoes and Jeremy Jahns and Maxie
Magic's and I have more coming for you
as well this video is to not something
really awesome are going to be doing
with my buddy Tom shadow bash you may
know him he's a fellow movie reviewer of
mine it's a huge collaboration that him
and I are going to be doing where we
both review a classic film that you guys
vote on and we take turns on each
other's separate channels doing that so
go over to his channel the link is in
the underbar below on that video is
called some good news and some bad news
make a comment telling us what film
you'd like the cs review if your comment
gets thumbs up and a whole bunch of
people say yeah that's the one that's
the one we'll do it however our first
video is already set it's going to be
collateral we're both big fans of
collateral and so we're going to review
that film because we think it's very
underrated that video will be on tom's
channel so you should subscribe to him
if you haven't more than likely you have
because he's freaking awesome wait
that's brick that's Victor's thing as my
uh oh yeah he's YouTube's most reliable
film critic no seriously check his
videos out there very good so I'm pretty
soon our first review is going to be for
collateral it's gonna be on his channel
and after that we're going to review
whatever film-- you voted on so go over
to his channel on that video and let us
know what you want to see and look
forward to it it's gonna be awesome